[Music]
welcome back
so we're talking about the cindy
algorithm and i've been walking through
some of the challenges that we face
and how we can overcome these with
things we've learned in the last five
years
since coming out with this algorithm the
big picture
is that cindy is a machine learning
procedure for model discovery that
allows you to take
time series data and discover
interpretable and generalizable
dynamical systems models uh that you can
use for
for things that you want like control
and prediction and understanding
okay good and we've gone through this
big picture overview
we've talked about how cindy works what
are the different pieces
and specifically we've highlighted these
four key challenges
and today we're on the last challenge of
the actual optimization algorithm
how do we get sparse models we've
measured the right data
in the right coordinate system we have a
library where we think
the dynamics should be sparsely
representable how do we
actually solve for a sparse model given
all of those ingredients
so that's what we're going to talk about
today and there's a lot of cool stuff
here
so i'm excited to tell you about this
one
all right good so again we're just going
to walk through this whole procedure
you've already seen this so many times
before you have data
that you're collecting for your system
you are approximating some derivatives
x dot you have a library of candidate
terms that could be in this differential
equation to describe
those x dot variables and we're going to
use some kind of a sparse regression
procedure
to find a sparse vector of coefficients
in c
that highlight or identify what terms
are active
in the x dot y dot and z dot dynamics
okay so today i'm going to talk
specifically about all of the
optimization algorithms that go into
this
why it works how it works and kind of
our philosophy
of sparse modeling and sometimes i call
this parsimonious modeling that
essentially just means
uh getting the minimal model that
describes the data
but no simpler okay that's a principle
of modeling
that's been valid for the last 2000
years and it's still valid today
and we're not the only ones that do this
so
bond garden libsyn and schmidt and
libsyn have this with their genetic
programming approach
miles cranmer does parsimonious modeling
with neural network systems and genetic
programming
this is our approach to the problem and
so today i want to walk you through
a few important parts of
this sparse modeling so that we can
really understand what's going on under
the hood
so this entire cindy procedure is a
generalized linear regression we have
data
x y z we compute their derivatives and
we build a library of candidate terms
and we're trying to solve for some
unknown variables
c given by these columns we want those
to be as
sparse as possible and still fit the
data
if we find a sparse c it tells us what
terms are active in that differential
equation
now the simplest thing you could do is a
least squares regression
you could just do a pseudo inverse of
theta and that will give you a
c matrix that has a little bit of all of
the terms active
that's what least squares does is it
spreads out that error by
by over fitting really and giving you a
little bit of
uh dynamics in all of those terms now
that will give you a good
model fit for x-dot a lot of the time
maybe better than a sparse model
but we believe it's overfitting to the
training data in some sense we don't
believe that the model
the true model should have 81 terms
active at once that seems far-fetched
based on what we know from physics
okay and so instead we want a
sparsity penalized regression that still
does a good fit
but has a as sparse of a c vector as
possible while still getting that good
fit
and there's a lot of algorithms you
could use to do this in the original
paper
we said that this is kind of like the
lasso algorithm
the least absolute uh shrinkage and
selection operator
from tibsurani 1996
and to some extent i feel like that
actually was a little bit of a
disservice or an oversimplification
we don't actually use the lasso
algorithm to solve this sparse
regression problem
typically it's not usually the best
algorithm to actually use to find sparse
sparse vectors c it's kind of morally
the what we're trying to do but there's
other algorithms that tend to work
better
so we actually cooked up our own
algorithm
called sequential threshold least
squares
and it's as simple as it sounds what you
do is you first do a least squares
regression
and you get a c vector that has a little
bit of all of the terms
but we notice that some of those terms
are very small
and if you hard threshold those and zero
those out
you can do another least squares onto
the remaining coefficients
now some of those are going to become
small and you can hard threshold those
and do a
least squares onto the remaining
coefficients and some of those become
small
and you iteratively apply this procedure
of doing a least squares hard threshold
least squares onto the remaining
coefficients hard threshold
until the model converges and this tends
to have way
better model convergence than things
like the lasso it's fast
it's accurate and it gives us very good
sparse models
okay there's a couple of catches here
so so that's what we do we do sequential
threshold least squares most of the time
but when you're doing this uh this
regression procedure we're constantly
balancing the
model error here with the sparsity of
the model
measured by how many terms are non-zero
we want as many zero terms as possible
while still having good model error and
this balance is controlled
by this
my clicker died
this sparsity of the model is controlled
by this lambda parameter here
and if i have a really big lambda it
says i care a lot about sparsity this is
the dominant term
and if i have a really really really
small lambda i say i don't care at all
about sparsity i just want a good model
fit
okay and so to some extent
that lambda if i have a very very
[Music]
small lambda essentially
then i'm killing i'm sorry if i have a
really big lambda lambda's almost
infinite then one over lambda is small
and for big lambda
i don't care at all about the error i
just want a sparse model
and there's no model that's sparser than
the model with no terms
so it gets me very low complexity but
very high error
and on the other extreme if i say lambda
equals zero i don't care at all about
sparsity
i recover my least squares solution
which
has very high complexity but relatively
low error
and by modulating this lambda parameter
this kind of
uh balance term here which we
essentially translate into where we
threshold our terms
you hope that you can find a family of
models from this
underfit to this overfit model and
hopefully it actually looks more like
this with a pareto optimal kind of elbow
here
where the really good sparse models are
and specifically if you have some
training data that you're training this
model on
least squares is going to look great but
the minute you have some withhold data
or some validation data
your least squares is probably not going
to perform nearly as well
on that withhold set because you're over
fitting to the training data
and so it actually there's this sweet
spot here
where you actually have less complexity
but that's more
reflective of the true physics
underlying your system
and that's where you hope that your
cross-validated cindy models
live is in this kind of elbow here so
key takeaways we
usually do a sequential threshold least
squares algorithm although there's many
that you could choose from
and you get to choose the sparsity of
your model by
adjusting this lambda parameter or your
thresholding value
and you can get models with more
complexity or less complexity
and sometimes when you don't know the
physics when you don't know the answer
it's actually good to get a handful of
models two or three or four models
on this pareto curve so you can compare
them and see what terms turned on and
off
as physicists and scientists and
engineers we can learn a lot about
systems
based on that complexity good
uh and i'll point out that there are
lots of approaches for
selecting the the kind of most
parsimonious model
we can use model selection from this
paper by neil mengen
or we can use these other optimization
techniques
and like i said there are other
perspectives
especially you know these genetic
programming perspectives
that also use cross-validated metrics
for parsimony
good now i mentioned this sr3
optimization algorithm this is
so we cooked up that sequential
threshold least squared
algorithm um you know essentially
just because it worked we tried a bunch
of things and that one worked and it
worked really well and so we ran with it
working with some real optimization
experts uh pong zhang
and sasha aravkin along with travis
ashkam
we essentially showed that our kind of
home brewed sequential threshold least
square algorithm
is actually a formal relaxation
of the l0 sparse optimization problem
there's many ways of relaxing it
lasso is one relaxation this sequential
threshold least squares is another
relaxation
and it essentially allowed us to
formulate a more general sparse
optimization
algorithm we call sr3 sparse relaxed
regularized regression so it's
regularized to be sparsity promoting
it's relaxed in the sense that there we
introduce
another variable w that kind of takes
some of the pressure off of the
c vector so c can be as sparse as
possible
and w can be close to c and give as good
of a fit
as possible and just that splitting and
that relaxing
goes a long way to making this actually
a much better converging algorithm
so we should do a whole lecture on this
i'm not going to go into too much detail
here
all of this code is open source and you
can read about it in
in this paper all of our papers are open
access
these days so you can just download it
for free from anywhere um
but often times we actually use sr3 as
kind of our
souped-up uh regression algorithm so
it's like sequential
threshold least squares but it's also
possible to add additional
regularizing terms and additional
constraints if we have constraints on
our coefficients that we know ahead of
time
we can bake them into this sr3 framework
good a couple other things you can do so
remember
we talked about reduced order modeling
of fluid flows
and i'm going to have a whole video on
sparse fluids modeling
but in lots of physical cases
there are there's prior information we
have
about our system we are not doing a
completely unstructured spur
search in this library uh for example in
fluid flows like this one incompressible
fluid flows
we know that energy is conserved and
more than that we actually know how
energy is conserved it's conserved by
a skew symmetry in the quadratic
non-linearities
so this is something that my colleague
john christophe law zoe pointed out to
me very soon after the first cindy paper
came out about five years ago
he emailed me and kind of told me about
this you know
rich symmetry in fluid flow equations
that we could incorporate
into our modeling procedure and again
this comes in as part of the
optimization algorithm
so so jc has partial knowledge of the
system he knows how to make it conserve
energy
by enforcing a skew symmetry constraint
in these quadratic terms
basically some of these quadratic terms
have to be equal to others
some of them have to be equal and
opposite and things like that there's
some structure
and so essentially you can perform
this minimization trying to find this
minimum error
but you can also have it subject to some
equality constraints on these
coefficients
c we can say that some of the c's have
to equal each other or be equal and
opposite or be multiples of each other
and this is pretty important because
because our algorithm is based on this
sequential thresholded least squares
it's basically
iteratively least squaring and then
thresholding
it's really easy to satisfy these
equality constraints at every step of
the least squared
optimization that's just the kkt
kind of version of least squares that
satisfies these equality constraints
and so that was a huge innovation that
jc introduced into this procedure
is that by kind of modifying our
optimization we can include equality
constraints
on these coefficients of c and get way
better model performance
so just to show you what this looks like
for energy conserving non-linearities
again in the navy or stokes equations
kind of in reduced coordinates we know
that this expression has to be true on
our model coefficients
and so you can essentially derive a set
of equality conditions
that have to be true for these cindy
coefficients
c and specifically you can derive these
uh very few equality constraints
that if you satisfy all of these
i guess eight constraints then
your system is guaranteed to conserve
energy by construction
and that's pretty remarkable so uh so we
can guarantee energy conservation by
enforcing these
and specifically we can enforce these
through a modified least squares
that would then be uh implemented at
every step
of our sequential threshold least
squares algorithm
and so when you apply this to fluid flow
systems
so here we're looking at the drag
coefficient on
these two flows and the white curve here
is the ground truth from a high fidelity
simulation
the yellow and blue are kind of the
previous industry best
reduced order models with three and
seven modes
they're not that great i mean they get
qualitatively the right behavior but not
quantitatively
but when you include these kind of
constraints
and either cubic or constrained cindy
you get much much
better agreement because by construction
or enforcing those dynamics
so i think this is pretty important and
one thing i always like to point out on
this
is that because these are sparse
non-linear models
there are only a few terms and you can
play around with them and write down
really really simple interpretable
expressions for what these dynamics are
doing
so this is an equation that jc wrote
down for the cylinder flow
and to date this is the simplest and the
most accurate model that i'm aware of
in the literature so those are the kinds
of things you can do
here um and i really don't want to
forget
something super important along this
stability constrained
cindy is some recent work by my phd
student alan captain auglu
who essentially used another version
of global boundedness condition that was
derived by schliegel and noak
in a 2015 jfm paper which basically says
there are conditions that have to be
satisfied for any quadratic model to be
globally
stable and so alan was able to
bake that into this cindy optimization
so that he is able to get
linear plus quadratic models that are
guaranteed to be stable
forever by construction absolutely
fascinating stuff
really cool optimization i'll put a link
to his video
and also to his paper in the description
okay other things you can do with this
optimization
there's a really kind of interesting
idea here that many dynamical systems
will abruptly change in time so maybe
i'm flying around in my aircraft
and something happens and i just you
know a piece of my wing breaks off or i
you know my my rotors get a little
gummed up and some parameter of my
system changes
most of the model might be the same and
maybe one parameter or two parameters
either change or get added or deleted
and so we have this version of cindy
which is essentially for abrupt
changes where we can very rapidly
learn small changes to the cindy model
faster than it would take to learn a
brand new model from scratch
again that's part of the optimization
procedure to get these really fast
recovery models
this is the kind of thing you would want
to do in real time for control systems
okay good so we've been talking about
the various challenges of cindy
uh in this lecture this is one of my
favorites because these are the
optimization algorithms
essentially sparse optimization is you
know a commodity algorithm now or set of
algorithms
there's many many to choose from uh i
only named a few of them i know if you
talk to
jc lawso he would have other
optimization algorithms
that he would recommend for you um and
and there's many more
out there for you to choose from but the
optimization algorithm allows you to
robustly find the model
once you have the right coordinates and
the right data and the right library
and it also allows you to bake in
partially known physics and kind of
prior knowledge
like stability or conservation laws into
those models
all right thank you